hey Kerry we're doing it again thank you
oh what a year it's been so far the
craze a year a lot of things that are
real a lot of things that aren't and I
don't know the difference but you are
the head of research for BuzzFeed videos
so you got enough I mean I can look it
up I don't know everything that I know
how to look at all Kari knows let's do
it
[Music]
so the first thing that's been pretty
crazy apparently Sean Spicer is a new
press secretary for Trump voice of the
White House yeah man who speaks for
everyone for some great apparently he
chews and swallows 35 pieces of gum
every day before noon wait a whole night
every day before noon that's what this
headline says but if you look back to
the original source which was a profile
in the Washington Post last year you're
gonna tell me this is true it seems like
fake news but it's real
every day he chooses Falls to a nap
packs by noon of orbit cinnamon gum and
his doctor's like whatever
thank you Father yeah what does that
look like in your stomach I don't know I
want to know if like when he poops at
2:00 p.m. if he's pooping an entire poop
made of gum and I want to know what a
poop made of gum looks like Ned come
here I got all these packs of orbits gum
I need you to chew up two and a half
packs that's 35 pieces survived and then
spit them out so I can see what it looks
like
all right Ned's chewing up in the gum Oh
what else we got so the other thing that
happened recently in his first press
conference after the inauguration he
said the inauguration had the largest
audience to ever witness an inauguration
period both in person and around the
globe which ever you want to meet it was
like that's not true because we have
these pictures oh I'm so glad I got that
in but it's true look at these
photographs yeah so the first one is
time Obama's first inauguration and the
bottom on is from Thompson operation and
both pictures were taken by The
Associated Press which is an unbiased
news worse give me a staff really
associated with Kerry whoa whoa deep
question I don't know I don't know
they give news to everyone both sides
left and right that's nice well we you
know maybe those are just shirtless
white people and that's just the glare
of their bodies on the camera and
they're actually there there's tons of
people there they're just so densely
packed and shirtless that it looks like
there's nobody there I mean I don't have
anything that says otherwise
you know and has mentioned shirtless
light people and any of the news sources
I've read in his second press conference
you followed up saying
when you add up all of the attendance
viewership total audience in terms of
tablets phones on television all the
various live-streaming that we have
information on so far it was the largest
watch inauguration ever you know it's
probably true there's more streaming
services out there than there were four
years ago and he just didn't word it
correctly which you know whatever but
he's doing all that gum it's not so hot
I probably just can't articulate words
super well I get that you know kind of
his job to be articulating things
clearly though he's the press secretary
so I guess the last thing that's pretty
crazy is apparently Sean Spicer has a
grudge with Japan does me asking me the
future
he's been tweeting for years that dibban
death is not the ice cream of the future
in 2011 he repeated I think I've said
this before but DIPA thoughts are not
the ice cream of the future even after
this 2011 tweet he actually tweeted in
September 2015
if dippin dots was truly the ice cream
of the future they would not have run
out of vanilla CC at the Nationals
weight at the Nationals yeah was he
trying to buy vanilla dippin dots it's
not like pies vanilla dippin darns
Shannon you're losing your credibility
when you hate a thing you don't go buy
it
when was this invented yeah Debenhams it
was founded in 1988 by a microbiologist
named Curt Jones 1988 is not in the
future no that's kind of the past
I think it's nice is right I think he's
right it's not the future should we
check back in with Ned oh yeah
Ned if you could try to with your mouth
shape it into a piece of poop and then
just poop it onto this paper I'd
appreciate that okay I want to imagine
this is Shawn Spencer's but around 2
p.m.
great great almost out and dropped oh my
god wow that's so much gum it kind of
looks like he pooped out a tongue well
Ned what did you learn from this do you
think you would have trouble
articulating correctly some things and
big press conferences after this it
makes sense why he doesn't always speak
correctly may
and great so everything spice is wrong
about totally excusable it's all orbits
fault
I will now tweet at orbits that they are
not the gum of the administration they
should stay at a Spicer's mouth maybe we
learned a lot about him as a person
today yeah diet is extraordinary yeah
all right well so next time I'm Keith
I'm Kerry Ned just burp real bad
[Music]